herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute.de 1 15 29 so heißt die neue
corona variante die zuerst im süden
afrikas aufgetaucht ist omikron wurde
sie von einer guten halben stunde
genannt und sie ist besorgniserregend
sagt die whu die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die ganze
welt ist in sorge vor dieser neuen
variante deutschland auch in der
kommenden nacht werden die flüge von
südafrika nach deutschland teilweise
eingeschränkt das heißt nur noch
deutsche staatsbürger dürfen zurück nach
deutschland fliegen und selbst dann
müssen sie in quarantäne
jens sparen der gesundheitsminister
sagte heute das letzte was uns jetzt
noch gefehlt hat ist eine eingeschleppte
neue variante die noch mehr probleme
macht auch die eu will die notbremse
ziehen andere länder ebenfalls es gibt
einen ersten fall in europa in belgien
wie gefährlich ist diese neue variante
was heißt es für diejenigen die geimpft
sind lässt sich diese variante aufhalten
und wenn ja wie wir sprechen gleich mit
einem experten aus wien natürlich könnt
ihr auch wieder wie immer eure fragen
und kommentare uns geben natürlich im
chat auch das wie immer und an die die
eingeblendete adresse zdf heute - live
at zdf de
beginnen wir dort wo diese variante um
sich greift in südafrika und da bin ich
jetzt verbunden mit unserer
korrespondentin in johannesburg hallo
sandra theis
guten abend
bisher war es in südafrika so zumindest
in den letzten tagen und wochen dass die
situation sagen wir mal glimpflich war
es ist sommer bei euch jetzt und das ist
dann in den letzten stunden passiert
also im grunde genommen was passiert es
ist dass die forscher in südafrika ganz
ausgezeichnete arbeit geleistet haben es
gibt in durban das sogenannte chris dass
es ein ganz erstklassiges
forschungszentrum die arbeiten zusammen
mit vielen anderen universitäten und
auch wissenschaftlern landesweit und die
haben sich
zusammengesetzt haben informationen
bekommen und eine neue variante entdeckt
es gab eine pressekonferenz gestern die
war da wurde gesagt das ist etwa 22
fälle gibt könnt ihr mich noch höheren
jaja behörden alles gut spricht weiter
seid ihr noch da
als wir hören die ich gut ich spreche
einfach weiter wenn es geht oder wenn du
mich hören kannst einfach weiter
sprechen
ok ich höre von euch nichts ich weiß
nicht ob das signal ausgefallen ist oder
ob ihr mich hören könnt was ich erzählen
kann falls sie mich hören könnt es gab
eine pressekonferenz gestern
zusammen mit den regierungsberatungen
behörden und eben auch den
wissenschaftlern vom christoph institut
in durban die haben die haben verkündet
dass diese neue variante eben aus ihrer
sicht relativ besorgniserregend ist dass
christen
so ich hoffe jetzt gab es
schwierigkeiten sand da ich glaube du
kannst erwerben dich hören können aber
jetzt hörst du uns hoffentlich wieder
sprich weiter also komm doch mal auf das
expertengremium darin dürfen zu sprechen
was dort gemacht wurde bitte
also wie gesagt dass crispin durban ist
ein ganz erstklassiges forschungszentrum
die forscher dort bekommen jede woche
hunderte proben von kliniken aus dem
ganzen land von kuwait patienten und
betreiben die sequenz analyse also die
genomsequenzierung das heißt sie
behalten ganz genau im auge welche
varianten im moment in südafrika im
umlauf sind und wie sie sich entwickeln
wo sie sich ausbreiten wie viele fälle
es gibt was sie gestern bekannt gegeben
haben war das stand gestern nachmittag
22 fälle von eben dieser neuen variante
b 115 29 entdeckt worden ist und dass
man insofern relativ besorgtes weil
diese variante kennzeichen hat und
mutationen trägt wie man sie auch von
den anderen derzeit zum damaligen stand
burkhard zeitpunkt gestern als
besorgniserregend eingestuften varianten
kennt und deshalb haben die alarm
geschlagen an die zahl der ausbreitung
ist im moment eigentlich noch gar nicht
so hoch wir hatten wir ja schon erwähnt
hast in den vergangenen wochen eine sehr
entspannte phase erlebt wir haben
durchschnittlich am tag etwa 200
neuinfektionen gehabt in einem land das
um die 750 millionen einwohner hat und
das sind natürlich sehr niedrige zahlen
bei etwa 25.000 tests am tag die
positivität rate lag bei nur einem
prozent mittlerweile liegt sie bei 9
prozent was passiert es ist dass die
neuinfektionen im vergleich von diesen
200 am tag gestiegen ist auf 1.200 am
mittwoch und mehr als doppelt so viele
am donnerstag heute lag sie dann bei
knapp 2900 und dieser sprunghafte
anstieg mittlerweile ist es eine
positive rate von 9 prozent bei den
tests ist das was den wissenschaftlern
hier moment eben die sorgen bereitet
hier kurz mal ein bisschen die situation
auch etwas besser einzuschätzen bei uns
gehen in manchen bereichen die zahlen
über 1000 manchmal sogar über 2001 dem
ersten landkreis die lockdown drohen wie
ist die situation dahingehend in
südafrika wie sie welche maßnahmen gibt
es und müssen derzeit befolgt werden
also im grunde genommen war es die
ganzen vergangenen wochen so als gäbe es
eigentlich gar kein cockpit im winter
war die lage noch ein bisschen
angespannt aber seitdem wir in die
wärmeren temperaturen gekommen sind ist
die lage extrem entspannt gewesen die
zahlen wie gesagt sehr niedrig gewesen
es war im grunde genommen so als gäbe es
kurve gar nicht es gibt außer einer
ausgangssperre die um mitternacht
beginnt und einige stunden dauert also
ich glaube sie endet morgens um vier
gibt es eigentlich gar keine
einschränkung auch der verkauf von
alkohol der monatelang verboten war um
die intensivstation nicht noch mit
zusätzlichen fällen zu belasten die
durch konflikte die durch alkohol
hervorgerufen werden ausgelöst werden
also auch das alles existiert im moment
nicht es gibt auch zwischen den
provinzen keine reiseeinschränkungen gab
es die ganze zeit nicht und sie sind im
moment auch nicht angekündigt wie wird
sich das sind jetzt entwickeln bei euch
beginnt ja bald die ferienzeit
ja das ist das was in der tat sorge
macht das eine ist die ferienzeit das
andere sind die examen und
abiturprüfungen also gerade im moment
laufen die letzten prüfungen sozusagen
für abiturienten aber auch an den
universitäten die fälle die jetzt
nachgewiesen worden sind von der neuen
variante betrafen vor allen dingen junge
leute das heißt es wird befürchtet dass
die jüngeren leute studenten die jetzt
möglicherweise partys feiern eben dazu
beitragen dass sich diese variante noch
relativ schnell weiter ausbreitet und
die große sorge ist eigentlich die
ferienzeit die weihnachtszeit winterzeit
hier die ferien beginnen ungefähr mitte
dezember und dann einen monat lang und
da fahren viele menschen natürlich aus
den städten in die provinzen in die
dörfer wo sie herkommen besuchen ihre
familien man feiert zusammen und darüber
hinaus gibt es eben das betrifft nicht
nur südafrika sondern auch die
nachbarländer südafrika ist ja ein im
vergleich zu den nachbarländern relativ
finanzstarkes land und wenn man dann
nach simbabwe oder malawi schaut zum
beispiel gibt es viele menschen die hier
in südafrika arbeiten und auch die
fahren natürlich daneben in dieser zeit
nach hause zu ihren familien und deshalb
wird befürchtet dass so wie im letzten
jahr getrieben von der delta variante
auch in diesem jahr jetzt möglicherweise
getrieben von omikron dass wieder eine
sehr große ausbreitung geben könnte und
dass es deshalb beängstigend weil das
gesundheitssystem natürlich in südafrika
bei weitem nicht so gut ist wie in
deutschland beispielsweise und da wird
befürchtet dass das natürlich
katastrophale folgen haben könnte letzte
frage kurze antwort bitte nur einfach
mal damit wir eine einordnung haben
können wie sind die impfbereitschaft und
die impfquote in südafrika
also wir haben zwischen 21 41 und 42
prozent der menschen haben sich
vollständig impfen lassen es war am
anfang relativ zäh weil es nicht genug
impfstoff und gab die impfbereitschaft
ist insgesamt aber niedriger als in
deutschland das hat verschiedene gründe
es hat kulturelle gründe es gibt aber
auch viele die aus religiösen gründen
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen und das
ist in der tat ein problem also im
moment ist die lage tatsächlich
umgekehrt wir haben mehr impfstoff als
wir moment impfwillige menschen haben
landrat heißt danke für den moment wir
sprechen gleich am ende der sendung noch
mal wollen aber jetzt dass etwas weiten
und fragen was muss man wissen über
diese variante was ist das besondere
daran wie es das zu bewerten was da
gerade passiert hier erstmal alle fakten
in aller kürze
noch nie ist das corona virus an so
vielen stellen gleichzeitig mutiert vor
allem haben so wichtigen stachel über
den sich der erreger zugang zum
menschlichen körper verschafft damit
könnte er leichter eindringen würde also
ansteckender zweite gefahr möglicher
weise erkennt selbst das immunsystem von
geimpften den mutierten stachel kaum
noch aus sie würden sich also leichter
infizieren könnte ihr impfschutz sogar
ganz weg brechen eher unwahrscheinlich
heißt es
den mit diesen fragen nach und da ist
mir jetzt zugeschaltet andreasberg
tanner nahmen sie sind virologe und
immunologe und leiter des centrums für
molekulare medizin an der
österreichischen akademie der
wissenschaften in wien eine schöne und
haben dort hinten
einen schönen guten abend dass wien ich
bin forschungsgruppenleiter dort ja das
so gesagt sein wir haben es vorhin
gehört alle welt ist sehr besorgt sie
auch
grundsätzlich ja ich möchte vielleicht
noch hinzufügen was ihre korrespondenten
trotz schon gesagt hat das ist hier
wirklich nicht um eine schuldfrage
schuldfrage geht das jetzt südafrika
oder irgendjemand schultag im gegenteil
ich glaube wir sehen dass diesmal die
wissenschaftliche gemeinschaft
extremster rasch reagiert hat und
dementsprechend sind wir aber auch an
einem zeitpunkt angelangt noch sehr
viele fragen
ungeklärt sind was wissen wir diese
variante b 1529 oder jetzt auch union
war getauft von der wm die hat äußerst
viele mutationen angesammelt mehr als 50
davon 30 in schwaig protein und davon
wiederum zehn in der so genannten
rezepte bindungsstelle warum ist das
relevant aber das ist genau die region
des virus womit das virus an die zelle
andocken kann an den zell rezeptor und
das ist eine sexuelle wand für die
infektiosität und andererseits ist aber
das sideboard in auch das ziel die
zielstruktur unser antikörper das heißt
mutationen dort können immer auch den
zusätzlichen effekt haben unter
umständen dass sie für so genannte im
juni skate eigenschaften sorgen
schrittweise nie komplett würde ich
jetzt mal behaupten sondern einfach ein
stück weit dass die antikörper nicht
mehr so gut binden können und die
jetzige situation ist die wir wissen
dass dieses wäre schon relativ hoher
jetzt mittlerweile ich glaube über 50
mal zumindest sequenziert wurde es gibt
ihnen direkte anhaltspunkte auf grund
von pc ergebnis dass es vielleicht schon
900 fälle gibt mit zumindestens dort wir
kennen noch einzelfälle aus hongkong
belgien oder auch israel das heißt die
große fragen die sich jetzt stellen uns
sind eigentlich zweierlei erstens ist
omikron infektions als delta das heißt
hat das eine chance global wirklich
wälder zu verdrängen und uns damit vor
allem neue herausforderung zu stellen
und die zweite wichtige frage ist ja
auch schon angesprochen hatten in ihren
beitrag ist ob oregon in irgendeiner
form unseren immunschutz unterlaufen
könnten dann geben wir das mal geben wir
das mal durch wald in der tat das sind
glaube ich die kernfragen dass wir die
erst mal der reihe nach zu durchgehend
für uns damals zum verständnis was führt
denn überhaupt zu solchen varianten zu
diesen mutationen wie es jetzt in
südafrika offenkundig passiert ist was
sind die einflüsse dafür
also wirklich wissen tun das nicht
inklusive bei der alpha variante die ja
im herbst letzten jahres in england
aufgetreten ist damals hat man vermute
dass dieses virus vielleicht in einem zb
immunsupprimierten patienten über
längere zeit reduziert hat und dabei die
chance hatte die zeit gewonnen hat um
weitere mutationen an zu sammeln da gibt
es gewisse wissenschaftlich
anhaltspunkte dass das tatsächlich so
sein könnte wobei das nie bewiesen wurde
für alpha eine zweite hypothese wäre und
auch das ist es wiederum da gibt es
weniger events eigentlich das ist
vielleicht tierische zwischen wird
begibt wo sich das virus besser anpasst
anders ist hier und da wieder
zurückspringt auf den menschen gab es
beispielsweise die nerzfarm in holland
und auch in dänemark im sommer 2020 aber
wirklich wissen wurde es nicht den
ursprung von omikron man kann jetzt
spekulieren dass es mit hiv infizierten
personen zu tun haben könnten in
südafrika aber da wäre ich sehr
vorsichtig das zweite ist was heißt das
jetzt für die antikörper tatsächlich
warum ist es infektiöser aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach oder das ist
zumindest eine besorgnis die heute
geäußert wurde was ist der grund dafür
also die befürchtung dass infektiösen
ist hängt glaube ich ganz ursächlich
damit zusammen dass wir in der provinz
gauteng oder auch in weiteren teilen von
südafrika in den letzten tagen einen
rapiden anstieg der neuinfektionen sehen
und es gibt hinweise aber wie gesagt das
ist noch nicht definitiv bewiesen dass
diese und um sind neue welle an
infektionen
aufgrund dieser variante zustande kommt
da braucht es gerade weitere
sequenzierungen und da wirklich sicher
zu gehen wenn das der fall wäre dann
würde man das eh in der vergangenheit
war ideologisch rechnen können die rasch
diese zahlen ansteigen kann damit eine
effektive produktionszahl berechnen und
kann damit quasi die intensität dieser
neuen variante beschreiben dafür ist es
aber noch zu früh
schauen wir an dieser stelle mal welche
besorgniserregenden und dazu zählt er
jetzt die neue auch welche
besorgniserregenden varianten des bisher
gab und wie sich das entwickelt hat eine
minute auf ihre varianten von saas kopf
zwei hatte die
weltgesundheitsorganisation
bisher als besorgnis erregend eingestuft
erstens die alpha variante sie wurde
zuerst in großbritannien entdeckt und
verdrängte im frühjahr
2021 in deutschland weitgehend den bis
dahin vorherrschenden wildtyp die alpha
variante ist ansteckender es gebe aber
keine hinweise darauf dass impfstoffe
substanziell weniger gegen sie wirkten
so das lka
zweitens die beta variante sie wurde
bereits im mai 2020 in südafrika
entdeckt auch sie gilt als ansteckender
als der wildtyp außerdem scheinen die
impfstoffe weniger gut gegen beta zu
schützen in deutschland konnte sie sich
bisher allerdings kaum verbreiten das
gilt auch für die gamma variante
zunächst in brasilien aufgetaucht auch
von ihrer sind laut lka nur wenige fälle
in deutschland nachgewiesen worden
ganz anders die delta variante entdeckt
zuerst in indien sie gilt als noch
ansteckender als alpha auch das
krankenhaus risiko scheint erhöht die
aktuelle vierte corona welle in
deutschland ist fast vollständig auf
diese variante zurückzuführen die
wirksamkeit von impfstoffen ist bei
delta verringert nach vollständiger
impfung bestehe dennoch ein hoher schutz
gegen erkrankungen und schwerere
verläufe so das lka
andreasberg tyler fragen wir nach diese
varianten und mutation macht das virus
das selbst aktiv um zu überleben oder
sind es äußere einflüsse die dafür
sorgen dass das passiert
frei nach charles darwin gibt sind sie
zwei prozesse die solche evolutionären
schritte führen dass eines die mutation
die muss entstehen das passiert ganz
zufällig im prinzip und und das kronos 2
hat ein genom mit 30.000 buchstaben an
jeder position kann es vier verschiedene
unterschiedliche buchstaben geben das
heißt dann jeder position könnten
theoretisch drei unterschiedliche
motivationen entstehen und dann gibt es
natürlich die möglichkeit dass diese
mutationen auch in kombination auftreten
also erstens ist muss montieren das ist
dem zufall überlassen dann aber was
wesentlich ist ob denn diese neue
mutation einen vorteil hat das virus hat
da dreht man die selektion
spielen eine rolle und die ist natürlich
sehr stark abhängig von der umgebung das
heißt von den status von von
verschiedenen anderen faktoren auf die
nötige unter umständen und mutation und
selektion die sind dieses wechselspiel
die letztlich dazu führen dass das virus
das beobachten eigentlich seit 2009 10
dezember buchen und china ab circa zwei
mutationen pro monat an sammelt in
seinem 30.000 buchstaben langen genom
unter spezieller über den varianten ist
unterhaltend ist jetzt angeführt haben
und insbesondere der omicron variante
dass sich diese varianten nicht so recht
an diese mutationsrate halten also die
haben nicht einfach zwei motivationen
ungefähr jedes monat angesammelt soll
die haben auf einmal wenn sie auftreten
20.30 mutationen mehr als endlich haben
sollten und da ist dann wiederum der
schluss dass es da zum beispiel annehmen
und routinierten patienten vielleicht
dazu geführt hat dass diese revolution
beschleunigt abgelaufen ist schauen wir
auf ein paar kommentare an dieser stelle
darf darin schreibt via youtube wir
werden dieses virus in der
menschheitsgeschichte nicht mehr los es
werden noch tausende mutationen folgen
und auch julia schilly via facebook klar
die nächste neue variante und das geht
jetzt immer so weiter ist da was dran
müssen uns einfach damit abfinden dass
hört nicht mehr auf es wird immer neue
mutationen und varianten geben
ich glaube wir wissen es nicht also
interview musste ich letzte woche gehen
hat zum beispiel haben wir versucht zu
erörtern mit anderen medien
jetzt ist es schon seit juni so dominant
zu 99 prozent vorhanden es gibt nicht
die so dynamik mit ständig neu auftreten
varianten war es das oder ist das das
ende der evolution der fahnenstange der
virus revolution und ich habe damals
gesagt wirklich wissen tun wir es nicht
es könnte theoretisch eine neue variante
im jänner auftreten oder so weiter aber
die informationen der letzten tage
lassen darauf schließen dass wir
vielleicht diese variante schon
vorliegen haben und ein sehr
wesentlicher punkt ist natürlich ob
diese variante auch wirklich sich
weltweit durchsetzt oder ob es am ende
des tages ein relativ regionales
infektionsgeschehen darstellt was dann
global weniger auswirkungen schauen wir
auf der stelle mal auf eine ganz
spannende und rasante grafik die wir
hier vorbereitet haben dies auch hier
auf zdf heute gibt kann man hier sehen
für alle um das ein bisschen zu erklären
hier fing es mal an mit der alpha
variante das war die erste
besorgniserregende die dann kam und ganz
klein da muss man wirklich schon sehr
genau hinschauen ist dann hier beta und
gamma und dann kam plötzlich die delta
variante fing auch ganz klein an und
dann sieht man wie das extrem steil nach
oben ging und gleichzeitig die alpha
variante verdrängt hat bis sie
mittlerweile im prinzip verschwunden ist
delta liegt mittlerweile bei
99,9 oder acht prozent also im prinzip
ist es die einzige variante die sich
durchgesetzt hat andreasberg tyler auch
da noch mal gefragt wie kann das sein
dass sozusagen eine variante die anderen
verdrängt die sind ja nicht weniger
anstecken warum sind sie plötzlich weg
gute frage und nicht möchte vielleicht
noch ein bisschen auch hinzufügen denn
über die übersicht die sich über diese
varianten geben die fand ich eigentlich
sehr eindrücklich und was wir sehen ist
dass jede variante ein anderes
eigenschaftsprofil hat und letztlich
auch an andere rolle gespielt in der
pandemie die alpha variante ist relativ
rasch innerhalb von ich würde sagen acht
wochen oder so hat die das
infektionsgeschehen übernommen nicht
weltweit überall aber in europa zum
beispiel war dass die dominante variante
ab jänner februar
ist einhergegangen mit letztlich einer
nachgewiesenen erhöhten infektiosität
von wahrscheinlich 30 bis 50 prozent
dann gab es die beta variante die hand
interessanterweise eigentlich relativ
starke im juni scape eigenschaften wo
man jetzt sich denken könnte das ist
besonders schlimm weil es die
immunantwort entkommt aber dieses virus
hatte dafür sich nicht so gut
fortgepflanzt dh man muss sich auch im
klaren sein dass die information in
servieren die es sehr eng gepackt und
männern eine motivation entsteht dann
kann das doch vielleicht einen vorteil
bieten im hinblick auf zum beispiel die
flucht vor antikörpern aber gleichzeitig
ist dass wir uns vielleicht nicht mehr
so infektiös das heißt das macht es
schwierig am computer vorherzusagen
sondern neue zusammengewürfelte
kombination an mutationen was das dann
bewirkt und beide eltern noch um darauf
zu kommen da ist dieser umschwung global
innerhalb kürzester zeit abgelaufen
eltern zum ersten mal im september
letzten jahres gefunden hat dann vor
sich hin geschlummert hat dann im jänner
februar in indien zu einer großen
pandemie weitergeführt und weiterer
folge auch nach europa england gekommen
und hat dann global eigentlich das
infektionsgeschehen übernommen das hat
keine andere variante davor wie es ja so
erfolgreich geschafft darüber wollen
genau das ist einer jener und weise das
unikat ist eine ähnliche weise schafft
ich glaube ist viel zu früh zu sagen
dementsprechend ich glaube es gibt
berechtigten grund zur sorge aber es ist
jetzt keine keinen grund zur panik weil
wir wissen einfach noch extremist
wenigen der hinsicht von shadow fragt
wie youtube gibt es so was wie ein limit
wie weit sich die ansteckt barkeit eines
virus- oder dieses virus noch steigern
kann das heißt kann man das streng
genommen ins ins unendliche steigern
oder oder kann ein virus eben nur in
bestimmter weise ansteckbare sein
ist natürlich eine sehr gute frage und
ich versuchen bei referenzpunkte zu
geben uns ein bisschen anschaulicher zu
machen die ursprüngliche wildtyp
variante des virus die quasi in china
delektiert wurde die habt eine
sogenannte re produktionszahlen wenn man
keine maßnahmen ergreift von circa 22
anhalt das heißt im durchschnitt hat
eine infizierte person sei andere person
infiziert im fall von der welt der
variante sind das jetzt schon ist zu
fünf bis acht personen die quasi von
einer infizierten angesteckt werden
könnte das heißt das ist deutlich eine
höhere intensität und wenn wir jetzt
wiederum was andere ins andere extrem
schauen zu den maßnahmen zum beispiel
diese maß und haben in der
produktionshalle von 18 das heißt da
würde durch den eine person 18 andere
infizieren das erklärt dann auch wie man
akademisch zumindest die härte
verbreiten kann man warum bei masern man
letztlich eine extrem hohe herren ideen
braucht von 95 prozent oder so bei
dieses virus infekts ösis das heißt das
spiel habe ich schon gegeben aber wie
ist ja dass das kaum noch immer 28
tatsächlich ausnützt wiederum steht in
den sternen soweit zur gefährlichkeit
dieses virus und dieser neuen
besorgniserregenden variante kommen wir
zum schutz und da geht es natürlich um
das thema impfen und die frage wie weit
wirkt der bisherige impfstoff oder die
verschiedenen versionen die es davon
gibt wie weit wirken also impfstoffe
gegen diese variante auch das ist zu
früh da schon eine hinreichende antwort
zu geben aber was sind die faktoren an
denen man es festmachen kann
uns versuchen einfach ganz kurz
zusammenzufassen
die moon antwort funktioniert die
besteht aus mehreren komponenten eine
wichtige komponente von der oder ständig
hören und lesen sind antikörper die
beenden an die oberfläche ist wir müssen
verhindern dass es den zellen einbringen
kann es gibt aber noch andere
komponenten des immunsystems zum
beispiel tequila hat sein das heißt dass
die muss dem israelisch komplex
aufgebaut aber primär schauen wieder zur
zeit eben auf antik aber auch über die
relativ leicht zu messen sind
und so gesehen ist die frage ob ronny
krohn mit seinen angesammelten
mutationen dieser immunantwort jetzt ob
sie team maßgeblich unterlaufen kann da
gibt es aus dem grund sorge zum anlass
weil wir viele dieser motor schon kennen
also omikron ist wirklich ein bisschen
wie ein briefmarkenalbum
briefmarken die die verschiedenen
varianten alpha beta gamma eltern mit
sich getragen haben auf einmal alle
versammelt in einem album städten das
könnte man sagen bei einer demonstration
hat dieses erstellen der rezeptor
bildung stellen das wurde dann
unternehmen zeitung der beta variante
dass das dazu führt dass antikörper
schlechter binden können aber ganz so
einfach ist es nicht weiß ist
kommunikation und gegenseitig
beeinflussen und das ist der grund warum
es wichtig ist auf erst forderten war zu
warten also neutralisation cez ist zum
beispiel die schon gestartet wurden aber
auch natürlich die epidemiologischen
daten abzuwarten inklusive den kliniken
im klinischen status und einem status um
da besser zu verstehen inwieweit die
impfung und wie wir sie zurzeit
verwenden unter umständen schlechter
dagegen um gefunden wirken celanese
gefragt wer facebook ob der booster
einen schutz gegen diese neue virus
variante bietet und vielleicht dazu noch
bei und hat heute angekündigt sich das
auch genauer anzuschauen es denkbar dass
man sich auf diese neue variante auch
einschließt
denkbar ist vieles ist natürlich reisen
uns nicht wie es dann kommt ich habe
insgesamt war es glaube ich immer nur
logisch eigentlich ein relativ klar
erfahrungsschatz die es das in der regel
je höher die höhere immunantworten wir
haben antikörper aber nicht nur auf
t-zellen usw je höher wäre unser
immunantwort pushen um so besser ist
auch der schutz auch gegen varianten die
vielleicht ein bisschen sich verändert
haben gegenüber der ursprungs variante
gegen die die impfung gebaut wurde
dahingehend obwohl der glaube ich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt keine anhaltspunkte
haben wie die bestehenden impfungen
gegen omikron werden gibt es gar nicht
trotzdem jeden grund dazu dass man sich
gerade jetzt in der situation eigentlich
überlegen sollte ob man sich nicht doch
noch die erste impfung heute oder sich
auf frischen ist um das nochmal ganz
explizit und ganz deutlich zu sagen eine
zusätzliche variante ist also aus ihrer
sicht gar keinen grund sich nicht impfen
zu lassen sondern erst recht ein grund
das zu tun
korrekt und falls bei einem halben jahr
mit einer neuen
variante kommt sie dann am besten
abdeckt oder oder eine weitere variante
kann das muss man abwarten aber ich
glaub es geht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
welt da geht es schon genügend gründe
über die jetzt mal behaupten baumann das
impfen lassen sollte natürlich viele
leute sind immer noch gerade in
deutschland oder österreich sind da
relativ zögerlich und ich glaube aber
omikron bietet einen weiteren eine
richtige
motivationsschub und ich möchte da zu
sein weil man oft auch diese
unterstellungen hört dass wir biologen
diese varianten aus dem hut zaubern
damit quasi die leute sich endlich
impfen lassen angst zu schüren aber dem
ist gar nichts oder gefallen als ich
glaube biologen wir hätten es lieber ein
bisschen ruhiger und dass er nicht immer
wieder mit neuen varianten konfrontiert
sind letzte frage noch aus ihrer sicht
lässt sich denn aus ihrer perspektive
die verbreitung dieser neuen mutante und
variante aufhalten zum beispiel dadurch
dass man flüge jetzt aus südafrika
streicht ist das ein wirksames mittel
ich glaube grundsätzlich beim kampf
gegen gegen infektionskrankheiten
wie jetzt auch dieses skoda + 2 ein
faktor ist seit je früher man handelt
umso besser auch mobilität ist ein
wichtiger aspekt dass man wenn man weiß
das ist eine regionalen cluster ried
oder so dass man die mobilität speziell
einschränkt aber ich glaube man muss
einfach so ehrlich sein sozusagen das
wären diese variante sich schon weltweit
ausgebreitet haben sollte und es gibt
erste anzeichen dass sind immer nur
einzelfälle und meistens reise
assoziierte fälle wie in hongkong zum
beispiel oder ich glaube auch in israel
dann wenn das denn schon so weit
verbreitet ist dann wird nur den
schwierig und dann kann man das glaube
ich maximal hinauszögern andreas buck
dollar danke für ihre informationen
einschätzungen dieser lage zum neuen
virus danke nach wie vielen dank schauen
wir abschließend den letzten minuten
nochmal nach südafrika db hat sich gegen
reisebeschränkungen ausgesprochen jens
spahn der gesundheitsminister dafür
reisebeschränkungen sollten immer gut
abgewogen sein mit genauer beobachtung
den sequenzierungen und
wissenschaftlicher zusammenarbeit ist
schon viel getan um diese variante zu
bekämpfen und mehr von ihr zu verstehen
wir sprechen uns zu diesem zeitpunkt
gegen reisebeschränkungen und für eine
wissenschaftliche herangehensweise aus
wir haben heute morgen entschieden dass
südafrika und weitere länder in der
region zu virusvarianten gebieten
erklärt werden werden
kurzfristig das bedeutet dass eine
einreise oder eine beförderung durch
fluggesellschaft nach deutschland du
noch für deutsche möglich ist und diese
müssen ob geimpft genesen oder nicht für
14 tage in quarantäne
fragen wir auch da man auch sandra theis
in südafrika wäre es gehört also
komplett unterschiedliche meinungen und
einschätzungen der sagt macht keinen
sinn jens spahn sagt doch keine flüge
mehr aus südafrika nur noch deutsche die
zurückkommen dürfen und müssen in
quarantäne egal ob sie geimpft sind oder
nicht wie sieht man das in südafrika
dass deutschland so reagiert
also in südafrika sieht man das
grundsätzlich natürlich sehr kritisch
gerade weil die infektion bei uns
natürlich noch sehr niedrig sind und man
eben nicht genau weiss zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wie gefährlich diese variante
tatsächlich ist und muss sich natürlich
auch fragen im vergleich werden die
leute die hier auf den flieger steigen
einen pcr-test machen und nachweislich
nicht infiziert waren als sie auf den
flieger stiegen
dürfen die trotzdem also müssen sie
trotzdem in quarantäne für zwei wochen
während in deutschland die leute
fröhlich in gasthäuser gehen und dort
ohne maske sitzen und der status geimpft
quasi dafür reicht und hier wenn man
geimpft ist und einen pcr test
nachweisen kann muss man trotzdem zwei
wochen in quarantäne das wird hier
natürlich mit einem großen fragezeichen
betrachtet und das große problem ist die
frage was das für auswirkungen letzten
endes hat also insbesondere für die
tourismusindustrie
ich habe heute mit einem kollegen
gesprochen also mit einem
reiseveranstalter gesprochen er sagt
alle leute alle reisen sind bei mir
abgesagt worden wir versuchen im moment
den leuten zu helfen hier am flughafen
von kapstadt wieder irgendwie nach
deutschland zurückzukommen und die
wissen natürlich einfach nicht wie es
weitergehen soll weil die touristen die
sagen wir fliegen nach afrika wir gehen
das risiko von mir aus ein dass es
möglicherweise ein sprecherin
entsprechend hohe infektionszahlen gibt
die müssten wenn sie sagen wir fliegen
drei wochen dann noch zwei wochen urlaub
nehmen weil sie dann nach zwei wochen in
quarantäne feststecken und das macht
natürlich keiner und das ist für die
tourismusbranche eine absolute
katastrophe und die hat sich bis heute
sowieso nicht von den harten lockdown
und der schwierigen phase dem ganzen
virusvarianten gebiet also dieser ganzen
phase sozusagen erholt abschließende
frage noch an dich wie ist denn die
situation insgesamt was das
gesundheitswesen anbetrifft in südafrika
ist man vorbereitet auf das dass es
möglicherweise wieder schlimmer wird
also ich glaube wirklich vorbereitet ist
man im grunde nicht wir haben im moment
noch sehr sehr niedrige zahlen und zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ist das
gesundheitswesen bei weitem noch nicht
an seiner belastungsgrenze die frage ist
halt wie sich das wirklich entwickeln
wird wir haben eine sehr junge
bevölkerung in südafrika und man muss
einfach schauen wie hat es dann
tatsächlich wirklich zuschlägt das ist
zeitweise sehr schlimm gewesen wir haben
offiziellen zahlen zufolge etwa 90.000
kurve tote die existenz also die über
sterblichkeit ist erheblich höher
gehalten phasen in denen massengräber
quasi geschaufelt worden sind in
anführungszeichen oder massenweise
zumindest einzelgräber natürlich
geschaufelt worden sind und keiner weiß
wie sich das jetzt entwickeln wird aber
der druck wenn die welle richtig hart
zuschlägt und das exponentielle wachstum
vorhanden ist dann wird natürlich auch
die situation in den krankenhäusern
relativ schnell sehr angespannt sein
dort heißt danke für diese informationen
aus johannesburg und abschließend denke
ich sind 2 kommentare hier noch zu
nennen die glaube ich den tag heute gut
zusammenfassen ela nur sehr rasch sagt
via facebook grenze schliessen bitte
doch das ist einfach und gut und wirkt
die eine meinung wir haben na ja sagt
via youtube meines erachtens muss man
global das impfen voranbringen damit
irgendwann möglichst die ganze welt
bevölkerung geimpft ist solange das
virus immer wieder neue wirte findet
kann es sich verbreiten das ist glaube
ich heute ein tag an dem man das noch
mal unterschreiben kann in diesem sinne
sagen wir danke für eure aufmerksamkeit
danke fürs mitmachen wir hoffen wir
haben einige wesentliche informationen
geben können die der tag heute bietet
man muss vorsichtig sein um das richtig
einzuordnen in diesem sinne danke für
eure aufmerksamkeit und bis zum nächsten
mal